(patriotic music)
- Hello I'm Grant
Grunderschmidt,
producer of Review
with Forrest MacNeil.
As you know our season one
finale ended with Forrest
punching me and then
storming off in a huff.
What you may not know is
that we've haven't seen
nor heard from him since
then, he's vanished.
Bygones are bygones and
we just want him back.
So we're appealing
to you, the public,
to help spread awareness
of this missing TV host
by using the hashtag
#FINDFORREST.
That's Forrest with two Rs.
This is not a joke
or a publicity stunt,
it's an honest appeal.
Won't you help bring Forrest
MacNeil back to Review
and then back to you
where he belongs.
Thank you.
Cut and you can put the hashtag
at the bottom of the screen?
- [Camerawoman] Yeah.
- Okay.
(solemn music)